[Music]
this episode is sponsored by ren a
website where you can calculate your
carbon footprint
you can also sign up to make a monthly
contribution to offset your carbon
footprint or
support rainforest protection projects
[Music]
so at the end of this episode i'm going
to say the thing that i usually say at
the end of the episodes
that thing where i thank you all for
coming on this journey with us as we
explore the unseen world that surrounds
us but
in the minutes we have before we get
there let's acknowledge something
most of the time the world that we are
talking about has come
from trees and ponds and beach sand you
know
the great outdoors the beauty of nature
but you know what's also great the
indoors it's comfy and cozy and it's not
just great for you
every time you go out whether it's to
run some errands or relax at the park
you bring some friends back with you and
when you wash your hands
some of those friends will end up
overstaying their welcome
in your sink
here at journey to the micro cosmos
we've been wanting to explore the world
inside our dreams for a while
but it's one thing to know what's inside
a sink
it's a whole different thing to know
what's inside
your think so understandably james our
master of microscopes was a little
reluctant to delve into the contents of
his own home's pipes
and then share it with the entire
internet
so instead he used a popular vacation
rental app
and rented the house next door and
checked their pipes instead
that's right he went to a vacation
rental and opened up the u-bend pipe
under the bathroom sink to gather up
some of the hideous slime he found
inside
it might help a bit to understand the
u-bend of a pipe
one of the things you don't want is for
your pipe to be an
open-air line to the sewer if that were
the case
you'd be able to smell the sewer from
your home
so every drain you've got has a little
u-shaped bend somewhere in it
and that u-bend is always full of water
that prevents
sewer gases from invading your home but
a place that is always
wet is going to be full of microbes
james has been collecting samples every
day for
years turning to all sorts of ingenious
methods and
uncomfortable situations to gather what
he needs but he said that this
was the first time he did not enjoy the
process
so thank you james for your service we
do
deeply appreciate it by the way now
would be a good time to remind you that
james's book the hidden beauty of the
microscopic world is available
wherever you get your books it lets you
hold the micro cosmos in your hands with
page
after page of beautiful pictures and
information but
back to drain samples the slime that
james was collecting from is called
biofilm you might find it in your drains
or
on other surfaces say a sink that hasn't
been cleaned in a while
and while it is gross to look at from
our perspective it's actually
kind of endearing when you think about
it from the microbes point of view
biofilm is a sort of community venture
bringing together microbes that stick
together for their collective survival
in our case you can see the long hyphy
of fungi
weaving together through the film
creating an architecture
that other non-modal prokaryotes can
cling to
also give us a moment to show off what
we think might be
a first for our channel archaea
it's not that we haven't been able to
see archaea before but archaea and
bacteria are both prokaryotes and with
our previous microscopic techniques it's
been difficult to distinguish between
the two
but archaea are an entirely different
kingdom
of life than bacteria archaea are likely
more primitive and they have different
chemistries in their cell wall
and their metabolism with our new
fluorescence light illumination we can
see
some autofluorescence emitting from
these samples
and we think those bits of
autofluorescence are archaea
glowing blue under the uv light there
are other beautiful bits of
autofluorescence that have come from
this gross slime as well like
this mysterious illuminated organism but
no matter how beautiful it is let's not
forget where these samples came from
a drain and drains are not exciting
for most of us they are a tool they're a
fixture a means to maintain our
environment they keep water contained in
traveling hopefully in
one direction away from us but for these
organisms
drains are their environment they're
dark
and damp and mostly protected though
they do go through
periodic flooding that brings new
nutrients and companions
forming a biofilm helps the organisms
contend with whatever we throw their way
including
making the microbes inside them better
able to resist disinfectants
biofilms may be gross and inconvenient
for us but they provide microbes more
stability than if they were
free-floating in their planktonic forms
but there are limits to the protection a
biofilm can offer
there are protist predators that are
quite content to munch on this community
which is bad news for the organisms
inside the biofilm but
great news for the protists it's also
great news
for more complex organisms like these
nematodes and rotifers
that need those protists to build out
the food chain that will ultimately lead
to their own dinner
and if that food proves to be plentiful
then they might contentedly and serenely
sift through clouds of bacteria
like this rotifer since we're looking
through the microscope and not directly
at the drain itself
we don't know what this individual was
doing when it was living in the sink
scum
but probably this was its life back when
it was living
tucked away in the u-bend of a
stranger's house
if you've been watching this channel for
a while you might find some of that
scene familiar maybe
surprisingly so maybe you were expecting
or hoping for
swamp monsters in the slime something
completely wild and different from other
things that we see under the microscope
but the familiarity
is kind of the point these things in our
sinks
are there because we put them there
bringing them from the surfaces around
us
it's an ecosystem of our own making
structured by
our architecture and fed by our own
daily adventures and
misadventures this house's drain is like
a little history
of the people who have stayed there
before a microbial guest book if you
will
and that extends to all sorts of drains
not just the ones in our homes
after all there are drains and buildings
and facilities where we work and eat
and visit and they all have their own
little ecosystems
fed by whatever is going on in that
building sometimes those ecosystems are
innocuous in food processing plants that
make cheese for instance
scientists have found the microbes used
to make cheese lingering
in those drains but sometimes the
ecosystems have their own monsters
like pathogenic bacteria found in
hospital drains
we might be studying this house's drains
for fun and education but for hospitals
those drains are both a record and an
indicator of disease
making them a concern for public health
while also providing us with the means
to understand what those concerns
might need to be because of course
no ecology exists on its own the drain
isn't just the unseen world around us
it's an unseen world
that we make and interact with all the
time in the stories of causes and
effects
that seem distant from the creatures
idling inside
it may not be born in the most elegant
of ways and it may never be beautiful to
look at from afar
but up close even a drain can be
breathtaking
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore
the unseen world that surrounds us and
thank you
again to ren for supporting this episode
of journey to the micro cosmos
ren is a website where you can calculate
your carbon footprint
and make a monthly contribution to
offset it by funding projects that plant
trees
and protect rainforests you'll answer a
few questions about your lifestyle so
you can see what your carbon footprint
is
and they'll also show you ways you can
start reducing it but no one can reduce
their carbon footprint to zero
so when using ren you can offset what
you have left
once you sign up to make a monthly
contribution to offset your carbon
footprint you will receive updates from
the tree planting
rainforest protection and other projects
you support
it's going to take a lot to end the
climate crisis but you can help by
learning more
at ren dot co use the referral link in
the description
and we'll protect an extra 10 acres of
rainforest
when you sign up all the people on the
screen right now
they are our patreon patrons they're the
people that let us
have a youtube channel where we explore
the inside of the drains
of vacation rentals and that kind of
person
we can all admit is a special kind of
person so we appreciate them very much
if you would like to become a patreon
patron
you can go to patreon.com journey2micro
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james weiss you can check
out jam and germs on instagram or on
tick tock
and if you want to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby